chelsey James covers the Washington
Nationals for the Washington Post kind
enough to join us on short notice
Chelsea good morning are the nationals
buyer's or seller's at the trade
deadline you know it's crazy to think
that that would be a question I think
you know this week I will have a lot for
now I think they're you know holding Pat
and I really don't see them making many
buyers I think the choice they have to
make is whether they kind of wait it out
or start sending pieces away I know that
it was thrown out there and the
Nationals responded but is there a
scenario where they would entertain
trading Bryce Harper what are your
thoughts on them it would have to be
extreme I think that you know they'd
have to do we see these next three days
go horribly for them and think there's
really no way they come back and do it
all people in that front office so you
don't have to think about it right you
can't look at his lost seasons they were
not going to get anything for Bryce you
know they didn't get a draft pick anyway
I think my loyalty is such that they
don't want this to end that way they put
so much effort into building a positive
relationship with Bryce they roll out
the red carpet they sort of don't pit in
his way don't step on his toes you know
it's a very you know touchy subject
around them you just kind of let Bryce
be Bryce so I really stunned if that it
came to that but I'm stunned that
they're in a position where we're even
wondering if anybody's going to be gone
soon but you have I think ten free
agents in the offseason Chelsea so they
I mean this is really an important end
of the season and offseason for the
Nationals you know Scherzer is what 33
we don't know what Strasburg you know
but his future is so like this is one of
those crossroads moments here do you see
that way for the Nationals
I do I feel a little differently than a
lot of people who tend to think that
it's sort of you know this is it the
chance I think that they could get
better next year they're gonna clear 88
million in payroll and even if rice
doesn't come back you can you can put
that money into multiple players instead
of just one so I think there's scenarios
where they're just as good it's not
better next year but when you look at
what the talent they have coming back
and you know the pitching talent
insurers are in Strasburg if they're
healthy and you were to sort of offload
veterans and get more prospects this
year I mean they'd be in a great
position moving forward so it's
definitely a crossroads moment sort of
default they're gonna be next year but I
think they were already gonna have to
redefine a little bit and with Scherzer
stands there you know Trey Turner Rando
and they're in a good enough position
where no matter what happens they're not
going to be totally irrelevant I'll say
what would the local reaction be if
Bryce Harper is either traded or doesn't
come back you know after the end of the
season I think I think traded trading
with your breath they've just never seen
this team throw in the towel so I think
that would be hard for people to swallow
but I think that city has truly been
bracing for Bryce's departure for a very
long time and it's kind of weird but I
honestly think that you know there's
sort of over it for lack of a better
phrase you know I think he's just it's
never really worse they've never won
with Bryce and and I think you know
there's sort of a little drama that
follows him so you know I think they're
ready it would be sad he's one of their
own guys but I think everyone sort of
ready for it and ready to move on see a
great player Chelsea
I think he is at times I think the thing
that makes him special is that he can
rise to that level at big moments and
sort of has a sense if it's the grand
stage in a way that you just don't see
very often but this year he hasn't been
he's been a good player and a very good
player it'll be interesting to see how
the baseball world assesses that you
know I think we'll see if more people
think he's good and gets a lot of money
are great and gets a historic amount of
money but I think maybe entering this
year it wasn't as much of a debate and
and now you're
people say is he is he that guys he
leaks and I think this year you'd have
to look at the numbers and say no he's
not he's very good he's helpful but he's
not transcendent you know do players
like migrate to him do you see a leader
I know we throw that around and
sometimes it sounds corny but it is he a
Pied Piper where people sort of follow
what he does or is it more you know
somebody else on the team he's not he's
not a leader very much keeps to himself
and it's funny we talked about this in
DC where you know he's the center of
attention all the time and I think it's
unfair people to say that a talented guy
should be a leader but Brice is more
than talented you know he's a
personality he's a presence he make
baseball fun again and millions of you
know bunny and endorsement deals he's
built himself into the face of this team
so I think that he hasn't emerged as
much of a stalwart and sort of a tone
setter has been a little bit of a
disappointment for people but he's not
he really is a quiet guy in the
clubhouse he keeps to himself he worries
about himself he loves to go home to his
family which he can't fault a guy for
but you know he's not the Pied Piper by
any means and in fact it is I think very
content to sort of slide into the you
know into his locker and be one of the
guys and and not be the guy who has to
you know answer for everything
Chelsea thank you for joining us safe
travels and enjoy the rest of the season
thank you thanks for having me let's
Chelsea James covers the Nationals for
the Washington Post
yeah I'm just curious the make up of
Bryce Harper because he does he you know
has the flamboyance the Flair but are
you building a team around him and I
don't know if he's a great player
because as as she said you know he can
be a great player well that doesn't make
you a great player he has the potential
he's had pockets he's had a season or
two seasons where he's been great but
I'm looking at you know he's sitting 216
25 homers he's been walked 80 times you
know what are you gonna give up for him
is he better than Manny Machado
now he's more popular I can sell him I
can sell him to a wider fan base
but is he better than Manny Machado
Machado is playing short and third now
if I can get those numbers at shortstop
you know that that separates him from
Bryce Harper in my opinion now with
those numbers
he just doesn't Machado has done it in
Baltimore and doesn't have the Flair he
hasn't been seen you know not endorsing
products and you know you don't hear him
being interviewed
yes point McLovin is right though about
him not seeing pitches he's gonna leave
the league in walks an intentional walks
this year he's never done that before
he's been walked a lot but since that
year in 2015 when he hit his MVP they're
there they're not giving too many
pitches yeah I wonder if he's gonna be
back oh he's that good back with the
Nationals yeah I've read looked at 10
list of potential teams and Nationals is
not listed on any of them wait there's
no chance the Nationals I'll tell you
they're the Yankees Dodgers Phillies
Cubs asked for then trade him yeah I
know that's what I'm saying you're five
and a half out of the wild-card spot so
you're you're not you're close but
you're not a contender yeah mclubbe but
may is that just the way people write
about him though does that maybe I'm
just reading like everyone loves the
column where's Bryce Harper gonna go
next maybe that's a media driven thing
well no if you're saying that you just
gave me ten teams in the Nationals
aren't on they're not I'm telling you I
just I've read like five articles today
and people are not talking about the
Nationals well they're you know there's
teams here the Diamondbacks the Giants
Mariners Indians then you throw in the
Cubs the Yankees are gonna be in there
as well but who's gonna give him a
10-year deal for four hundred million
dollars the Yankees would you think yeah
they're like famous for exactly that
move but haven't they haven't they've
written back a little bit in recent
years on some of that and the tax that
tax thing I mean you're paying stanton
300 million or close to it you imagine
him with that short right porch oh man
so you'd have judge and Stanton and
Bryce Harper come get come get you some
for more Dan Patrick show to Dadi
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]